Mr Speaker all across the country people
are worried about their bills the price
of the weekly shop and the spiraling
mortgage rates
so why has the Tory party spent this
last week arguing over which of them
gets a peerage
[Applause]
prime minister well Mr Mr Speaker not my
points on this are very clear in line
with a long established Convention of
previous Prime Ministers having the
ability to submit honors I followed the
process to the letter in conventional
long-standing process it is it is by the
way Mr Speaker a long-standing
convention that prime ministers on both
sides of this house have followed in the
same way that I did Starbucks
Mr Speaker
truth is for all
talk after the event the Prime Minister
did sign off the honors list and that
means that means Mr Speaker that those
who threw a Downing Street party the
night before the late Queen sat alone at
her husband's funeral will now receive
awards from the King
if he's so tough
why didn't you block it
[Applause]
Mr Speaker as I said I and the
government followed due process and
Convention Prime Ministers Prime
Ministers of both parties have always
upheld the convention of
non-interference on political honors my
predecessors may not have agreed with
Labor's choices of Tom Watson or shami
chakravarti
but the same but the same precedent Mr
Speaker the same precedent stood then as
it does now and I'd expect a night like
him to understand that
I think we will have more if we carry on
it'll be more outside rather in here
Kirsten honor should be for public
service not Tori cronies
but Mr Speaker isn't this the case he
was too weak to block Johnson's list and
that also means that those who spent
their time helping cover-up Johnson's
law breaking are rewarded by becoming
lawmakers for the rest of their lives is
his message to the British public if you
don't like it tough
that we use the honor System to
recognize people almost 2 000 people a
year from members of the
lioness St
s officer in Greater Manchester but he
talks he talks about people putting
people in the House of Lords perhaps he
could explain why he put forward for a
peerage the former MP labor MP Tom
Watson who spread vicious conspiracy
theories that were totally and utterly
untrue damage public discourse and
inflicted misery on innocent people
[Music]
I just said Supply minister
you shouldn't criticize other members
also you're not responsible for the
other parties you are the Prime Minister
that's answering the questions now
asking the question here's some um
[Applause]
if somebody wanted to challenge my
decision
Kirsten
Mr Speaker the truth is the country is
paying the price of this endless cycle
of chaos and distraction the Tory
economic crash means that millions of
mortgage holders will pay thousands of
pounds more next year and the blame lies
squarely at the door of a government
more focused on the internal Wars of the
Tory party than the needs of the country
does he not think that those responsible
should hand their heads in shame
Mr Speaker as I said right at the
beginning of the session our number one
economic priority is to reduce inflation
so that we can restrain the increase in
interest rates but one thing we know
that we need to do to do that is to
reduce our borrowing and debt Mr Speaker
that's how we will bring interest and
mortgage rates down but last week what
do we see labor confusion with the
shadow Chancellor attempting to walk to
water down their plans to borrow 28
billion pounds more a year but she was
promptly overruled by the shadow Energy
Secretary the former leader who said
that they were 100 not abandoning their
pledge it really looks like Labor's
offer never changes it's uncontrolled
borrowing and more chaos with Ed Miller
Band
[Music]
there's only one party
there's only one part that broke the
economy they're sitting right there
they can't fix the problems facing the
country because they never take
responsibility for the damage that
they've done and it's not just Johnson
the prime minister's immediate
predecessor is hoping to reward those
who made her Reign such a rip roaring
success
on her honors list are the masterminds
of that Kamikaze budget the economic
extremists of The Institute of economic
Affairs those whose disastrous ideas
crush the economy and left the country
to pick up the pieces will the Prime
Minister block that honors list or will
he Buckle to her as well
Mr Speaker
if you want disastrously economic ideas
all you have to do is Labor's economic
policy on the energy
[Applause]
policy that seeks to ban all new British
oil and gas drilling Mr Speaker
jeopardizing 200
000 jobs and our energy security at a
time of international conflict despots
like Putin are the only people who will
welcome such a policy okay his pre his
predecessor once said that he wanted
British jobs for British workers his
policy is British jobs for Russian
workers
[Applause]
[Music]
if he spent as much time focused on the
economy the NHS and the Asylum system as
he does haggling with his predecessors
about who gets honors the country would
be in a far better state but once again
he's lost control and once again it's
working people paying the price and if
he disagrees with that why not put it to
the test end the boasting the excuses
the Tory chaos see if he can finally
find somebody anybody anywhere to vote
for him and call a general election now
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker he talked about
Asylum just this week just this week it
was the labor party that voted against
Plans to tackle illegal migration just
this week it was a labor party that
voted against Plans to tackle disruptive
protesters by their funding Eco sellers
Mr Speaker but we're getting on and
delivering for the country we're
delivering record employment and the
fastest wage growth in years Mr Speaker
it's clear only the conservatives are
going to deliver for the people of
Britain
jobs